I wonder if you can see back to the very
first lesson we had this term and I
introduced to you
the mathematician every no I thought
right and I said that among many of the
things that she did as a mathematician
and physicist she introduced this idea
of a field
do you member what a field was it's a
very strange kind of object but it was
very closely related to this this is not
a field but it's a question or that idea
what is this it is set right can you
remember this this object is and you
have in custody before can you remember
how do we define a set what is a certain
eye it's a group of what you say okay so
scores these could be scores I'm going
to point out the idea of a set it's much
broader than so it actually can be a
collection a group of pretty much
anything I'm actually not going to use
the word group because group is another
mathematical idea and there's this whole
subsection of that called group theory
so I think collection is a good word to
use
so job is back down because this topic
today's concept is built upon this again
in a different way that would be able to
make so a set is just a collection of
objects you can have a finite collection
of objects such as you know gender
crystal quarry and jazz at this finite
set object or you can have an infinite
set of objects on the top this goes
forever so this is a set of all odd
numbers right now we sort of added on
extra conditions then I won't revise you
can go back to the first week if you
like we added extra conditions if you
have a special kind of set it becomes a
field well if you take a set and you add
order to it if you take a set and you
add order what you get is now a sequence
okay so one three five and seven are odd
numbers but 735 and one also odd numbers
and that would be our constants have set
okay
but a sequence a sequence
is a set with water
so when you see sequences we do look at
how the curly braces around so I could
legitimately say when we talk about this
sketch done totally meters finite now is
that like eighty before this set and
this set are the same okay but this
sequence was briefed on etc is not the
same as this sequence seventy by one
okay so that make sense when you're
looking at sense you don't care what
order they're written in just kind of
like a pile of numbers or objects or
whatever but will you have it a sequence
like things are sequential the order in
which you give them values the sequences
are built off of sets and theories in
other clock sequences service series is
what happens when you take a sequence
and you just add everything up that's
what I do so it's not a set before up
other sequences a series is the son of a
disease okay
absurd for example one plus three plus
five plus seven that is here this is a
finite series just like we have sets
that can be finite or infinite you can
have to find out or input sequences you
can have finite or infinite series so as
in double you could have that this is
really one so nothing nothing
so everything that applies dispense you
can sort of sit as a parallel just like
finite infinite for that company so how
do we define the how do we describe our
this set or that or this sequence this
series etc so underneath here a little
sub set heading which is how to define
sequences in series
can't you define there are three ways
if I want to describe for you a sequence
or series and I want to say this one not
that one it's a particular kind of
sequence or series there are three ways
to do it
the first way is the one that I've
already shown you on the board which is
establish a pattern okay if I leave
enough terms you can see like I don't
need to tell you what the nurse to balad
or with the next term be one over
sixteen or the next will be whatever the
this two and 24 and so on so you've got
enough time period to establish a time
establish a plan now generally speaking
is degree that you need three terms in
order to do that return and I'm going to
give you a quick example that shows you
why it's three if I said to you
okay skin sequence 1 comma 2 dot if
that's all they gave you you don't have
enough information yet to really know
what the next term is and what is it you
be but there's two obvious examples that
are possible for instance see this what
we open this with you how do you advance
from one term to the next what do you do
make sure you add to likewise 2 plus 2
plus 2 is a common difference between
each term so if I apply that logic here
there's one within extending 3 there's
more than 5 so this would become the
counting numbers do you agree
that's totally plausible but have a look
at this player here advance from one
term to the next there is not a common
difference you don't add or subtract
anything each time what do you to use
divide by 2 or you multiply by a hub
right so here there is a color
difference that might be work drug down
there's a common difference here whereas
for this theory is you don't have a
color difference you have a comment
where there is a common ratio
so when you've only got two terms at
least for these kinds of different
things I'm going to show you a couple
one in a second you have no idea what
comes next because it could be either
the exams this could go one two three
not a dot or it could go one two four
dot dot right so therefore you really
need the third term to establish the
pack obviously you can provide more than
three but generally speaking what you
had third we don't need to provide any
so establish a pattern you can also
define a sequence or series let's see
with a popular so the formula is going
to give you the editor here's what I do
I can describe either of these by going
straight to a particular term defining
that term and say the first term is this
the second term disk the third term and
a dot dot the nth term whatever that
might be
so for example this one CR I played the
nth term so I would write it so T term
and being a subscript to that particular
one you're interested so that one there
would be let's see here I guess I would
always say like this too
to end those do you see how this will
give you this series or the sequence
okay I say okay what's the first term t1
well I'm going to substitute in 1
everywhere I see em so it will be 2
minus 1 which is 1 if I want to the next
term so 2 it would be 4 minus 1 which is
3 and you can see what are you in by
leaders of this is that you can go
immediately to any term that you like
you have another good term rather this
the at the first 99 then you get to 101
the hundredth time you could immediately
see is going to be 199 200 minus 1 okay
so this still defines this series or
this sequence it gives you enough
information and it's a little more
concise okay it's on last way which is
through what we call a recursion now a
recursion is very similar to this
formula idea but instead of saying goes
straight to the f1 you say it will just
tell me the start and tell me how to
keep going okay so for example again I
write this one three five seven I should
say term one is one the first time and
then to get to the next term
that's my waiting the nectar you just
take it pretty stir and add to that's
what you taught me before to do write to
advance you just add to every time so
you know way to start and then you know
how to keep going so I might even write
that where you start
and how do you advance from one term to
the next and then you could define every
other term in that way it called a
recursion or a recursive formula because
since part here on the right hand side
the part that makes it work it's
something from first to itself it's sort
of circular right
these pans here or these ways of
describing sequence and students are
much more common sense and they're a lot
easier to use but there are some
sequence in the series that this is
really the only way or the most
efficient way to do it now think of your
famous example that you all know so this
is a sequence what's the name of this
Dickens this is the Fibonacci sequence
even there was a people before Fibonacci
discovered it how would you define this
how would you explain it well I've done
the pattern I've established pattern
okay but it's not more common to define
in a repressive way like that's how you
actually get from one number to the net
I just say what the first number is
you're sewing a second come on and then
what do you do how do you get to the
next term you're going to look at the
previous one and also the one before
that that makes sense doesn't it like
you look at me too to get this you look
at these twos if this and so on
so again you can see the recursion you
get sort of refers to itself